i see that phone yeah absolutely so here
i'll uh should i un
open it to the camera so this is the box
yeah should i be fancy with it yeah
should i be fancy
show the people the time for it so i
looked it up so this is the freedom
phone guys
and all that it's beautiful it's a
beautiful box okay cool
cool yeah i'm bumping my microphone here
so here we go all uh
you probably your your frame is probably
like at your chest okay okay so there we
go so this is it
and all that that's a little bit up a
little bit there you go
it still darkens the camera because the
white yeah yeah absolutely so here we go
um here i'll hand it to you in just a
second and all that but yeah this is
what it looks like
you know it's a quality phone um and all
that and then oh yeah
it's a quality phone and all that and
you can boot it up you know we did uh we
we basically combined some of the best
um custom roms uh on android plus
i hired a really great cto on to
basically re
rebuild um you know and rebuild android
from the ground up so that way you can
uh
that way it was secure and all that's we
mixed lineage os graphene os
um we took some of the best parts of all
these things and then you know it was
tricky to do because that can that could
break a lot of things um and we did that
and uh and then yeah so you have like
trust on there
which is a a kind of a privacy guard for
your phone
and then you put it up um and then we
have uh
here i'm just trying to think one of the
things we did is we made this really
explicitly kind of
uh political in a way because we thought
about making like should we make this
phone like a little bit more
um like a little bit more neutral um in
a way um and not so like hard standing
on on on kind of free speech and and you
know right wing politics
and all that but we wanted to you know i
feel like we did a good job we wanted to
have like
i'm never afraid i guess of being
provocative and i think a lot of people
they don't they're they're i can hand
this to you by the way if you want to
play with it
yeah um freedom film though yeah freedom
phone how long did it take for
the duck duck go on it oh yeah so duck
duck goes right on the home screen
brave browsers yeah we pre-load fortnite
because we did that as a troll
because uh apple apple banned fortnite
um off their app store
so again they're they're not just uh
they're not just banning conservative
apps
they're banning apps like fortnight if
they don't pay up or if like some
governments
like for example not that i use this app
but but grinder i mean that's you know
like tinder for gay people
i mean that's they ban that they ban
that not in the u.s but a country asked
them to bail i forgot which one but it
was like so the
so they're responding to countries and
all that and that's the problem with
these huge
huge multinational corporations is you
know they they're just in it for the
money and all that and that's the whole
purpose of
of of this phone and all that was uh was
was to make a phone
that was a true alternative to the to
apple and google do
apple and google multiple sim slots yeah
you got multiple sim slots and
everything
um and all that so how long did it take
from the drawing board to prototype
and then from the prototype to finished
product you can connect the connected to
wi-fi too if you want to use the
internet so that's like a test unit so
where's the camera
use the camera so it's at the bottom
right corner oh i see yes
exactly oh
looks like a camera yeah it zooms look
at that
hi so i think uh uh i'm looking at the
specs
and i think the umidigi a9 pro actually
has a better camera uh
yeah so we we customized the camera on
everything like the problem is is we
wanted to make sure that on the supply
chain front that we got our parts in a
secure way
um and all that so that way uh like we
just didn't feel satisfied with the
umidigi
um their camera supply chain oh yeah
absolutely oh i see well
i i googled it they say they have a 32
megapit a 32 megapixel
megapit megapixel uh uh a camera
actually has a
less uh uh they have an octa-core
processor which i think yours is also
also we have an octa-core processor but
yours is eight gigabytes right
um oh no no no
this is great man four gigabytes yeah
yeah it's epic that one human can build
go and do something like this wow i mean
obviously you have a team of 20 people
and factories
and research and factories how long did
it take you guys from start to finish
it took a year it took years so again
this started out as a uh as kind of my
background was crypto and all that we
thought well would it
be great to have a phone you know
pre-loaded with a bunch of you know kind
of blockchain based apps and everything
um and uh and we thought about that but
one of the reasons we wanted to call it
a freedom phone
was to have that provocativeness and to
go right into the
like i think that there's a huge problem
of people a lot of people you know
if they voted for trump they don't want
they're scared to market
to uh uh and you know i voted for trump
and and and everything they're scared
to market to these uh uh scared to
market to this
to this audience you know you see look
if there's like a pillow company right
that's the least political thing ever
but if they they say they care about
your values and they do
um you know they they end up they end up
doing well but getting hated
i know so many friends they have some of
the best online alternative education
apps in the world that would appeal in
my opinion to
a lot of right wing people that that
care about alternative education because
right now the
the education system itself in my
opinion it just teaches you know
crt and a lot of left-wing values and
you know you could say you can have that
argument
but in my opinion there's no ideological
diversity so that's another reason why i
think i'm getting attacked so much is
this
i'm unapologetically free speech you
know i'm una
in my opinion you know i'm a republican
so and i think that's the
and it's weird because it flipped it
used to be that republicans back in the
day in the george bush era
they were kind of a little bit you know
not so good on free speech and it used
to be the left and it's totally flipped
now
i'm like a one issue voter i just care
about free speech yeah i think
centralized education is a big problem
it is good to build social cohesion
through what we understand and know but
i think the modern day education is
teaching people how to learn not what to
know exactly and this education system
seems to be shoving specific information
into people's heads as opposed to
teaching them how to think critically
which exactly i mean i dropped out of
high school because i love to learn
not and that was and that was the
problem is is
you know you look at richard branson he
dropped out same age as me um and all
that is
i i love to learn and that's why i had
to leave because
they i i felt like if and that's one of
the reasons why i care about free speech
because
i was like you know i've done a ted talk
um i had met you know with with jimmy
carter
and and all that like time magazine
realized the media had liked
me up until july 14th when we launched
this phone
and all that and uh like i had all these
like literally i did an interview with
um business insider
um and all that before they didn't know
that i was launching the phone and it
was very nice
um cnn had me on to talk about crypto
a few days and they didn't know and they
wrote these glowing things um but
uh about me so i i pulled up i had the
wrong specs before i had the a9 pro on
the a9
the specs look the same yeah what's the
difference between the pro
and the i guess the pro is a better
camera it's marginally more expensive
so but but let's let's get down to brass
tacks here the specs look very very much
the same
same camera front and back uh this
display is the same
they say they have a dot what is this a
dot drop display
not the same as the the what what do you
what did you just what is it what does
the freedom phone have is it um
water drop is that different no no oh
well yeah i mean it's like i mean
uh is it different i mean they i think
that's their name
for for just a again i haven't looked at
like the a9
specs really so why is it more money why
is it more money
um well one to to to source
all the uh the parts of this device um
we you know it does cost more money to
be able to get the parts we get from
because
if you don't want a supply chain reliant
on
you know let's say ccp companies or
whatever it ends up being a little bit
more expensive a little bit more pricey
um and also when you do things at scale
the overall product ends up being
cheaper
so when people look up the price of
these phones uh
you know a lot of these prices it's for
ordering you know 50 000 units at once
because companies did and they can sell
it because it's exactly yeah yeah so
or another company does it and then yeah
they resell it at that cost so they're
the the root cause of these phones
they're selling 50 000 or 100 000 phones
and then yeah they either resell um or
or
you know that it counts as as as buying
a hundred thousand phones or something
um or what what does the operating
system do because
because look regardless of the reason
why it costs
you more money like why should someone
spend more money on a phone that has
effectively the same specs as the a9
well yeah i mean
at the operating system level i mean we
i mean if you buy that if you buy that
phone
i guarantee it it has a ton of google
stuff on i mean
not just guarantee you can look it up um
it has a ton of google stuff on it it
uses the google play store
which totally tracks you and it's uh the
supply chain has not been verified
um and all that and we're gonna post on
you know our whole supply chain process
which i think
on on our website um coming up and then
we just we just got out there and it was
like a crazy launch
so you know we just we we honestly did
not expect to honestly have it kind of
blow up this much
what is right now is that basically like
the freedom os yeah freedom os is a mix
of uh lineage
aosp android open source lineage os
graphene os
couple other custom roms and our own
touch and uh
so one of the things we do on this phone
is we silo every app in its own little
digital island its own little digital
bubble
so that way it can't see anything that's
going on the rest of it oh that's
awesome
yeah exactly so sandboxing yeah
sandboxing so uh
uh you know like right now and i on
iphone i think in even apple developer
analytics just as a normal developer
you're able to
yeah yeah you don't have youtube on that
phone do you uh no no youtube is uh
uh you you have the option you know it
annoys me what
when i'll try i'll be using the browser
on my phone and i'll go to reddit and
then it pulls up the app instead
oh that's so annoying it's telling you
to do it and there's been periods where
i've had to do like i've been out right
so like i'll record everything and then
i'll leave
and then i'll get a notification from
someone will message me and be like oh
hey there was a typo in the in the
thumbnail or something
or typo in the in the title so i'll have
to go in
to the to the to make changes but every
time i go to the browser to try and
log into the browser it pulls up the
youtube app
and then not the actual like studio so i
have to i
have to actually delete the youtube app
because the apps
all connect to each other exactly the
browser should be independent from other
apps if i'm in the browser and i need to
pull up a site for a specific reason
and i i can't remember the specific
reason but i i think it's because um
the youtube studio app doesn't actually
allow you to effect i think monetization
you have to go into the browser to do it
but then the browser default pulls up
the youtube app not even the studio app
and then i can't go in so i delete
youtube from my phone
log in fix it then reinstall you might
be able to fix that in settings
and have it so it doesn't auto default
to the app yeah
ultimately that's what i had oh good
yeah something like that like don't
switch
are there oh sorry um are there have you
guys looked into setting up anything
that allows you to mine cryptocurrency
on your phone while it's active the
problem with that is uh i mean we could
you know give you the option do that but
your phone is uh
it doesn't have this headphone is a
great processor but for a little like
bitcoin mining
that takes like a huge amount of
processing could you tap into a mesh
network and be part of a
a group of nodes that we're mining i
don't think the money would end up being
worth it for you so yeah you could but i
don't think it'd be worth it for you 500
bucks is steep man
4.99 um yeah i mean you know we give
coupon codes 50 bucks off and you people
can pay monthly if they want to
um and all that but uh but yeah i mean
to me i mean you know you see the phone
feels as good i mean you have a thousand
dollar iphones even 1300
iphones we didn't want to like cheap out
on in my opinion the quality
you know i'm thinking about it because
i'm like i understand
you know some of the arguments people
make they're like dude the a9 is cheap
and i'm like if i wanted to buy the
phone right now and i wanted to get
someone
without them having to worry about it i
want to get them a phone that's not
being tracked
that's got these these apps that have
been censored they can get access to
that's going to be hard for me to do
like like i'm thinking you know what if
i were to just buy
a hundred of these a9s and then just go
through them and then load up a new
operating system there there'd have to
be so much stuff you'd have to do to
make sure it works and quality control
i probably won't be able to do that i
got to be honest i think 500 bucks
sounds steep but i stand by what i was
saying earlier that
if if your device does what it says it
does and you're providing a service
effectively hardware be damned if it's a
service that provides people with
instant access to
a clean operating system that doesn't
track them and provides them a way
around censorship
that's seriously that's it's massive
also you're not using slave labor right
yeah no no and that's that's another
thing is just yeah i mean
to me i feel like the real story of this
is that you know what like
apple like i always thought it'd be
great if um if if some president
had put sanctions on on the import of
any
goods made by slave labor because that
would just shut down
a lot of these big phone companies and
and hold everything up because it's bad
yeah but then the american people would
be like why does my phone cost 10 grand
i mean you know i think well trust me we
we make this phone what isn't it doesn't
have to it doesn't have to cost that
much if if you're not using
using that kind of labor and all that oh
yeah yeah yeah hong kong is
has got problems right now but i don't
yeah they're not
well actually i don't i don't know for
sure foxconn is not in hong kong they're
in uh they're in taiwan
they're in taiwan really yeah yeah well
they have they have they have stuff from
i mean exactly foxconn is in taiwan i
believe they're a taiwanese company
fact check me new york times fact check
me right now eric yeah isn't an iphone
like
a thousand dollars yeah exactly an
iphone is like
i thought it was oh okay you're right
shenzhen yeah that's why people are
committing suicide
yeah yeah yeah okay good i'm glad
because i was like i was like i like
taiwan you know and all that yeah i was
like no
yeah i thought it was gentle yeah new
york times fact-checked me but yeah i
mean with the phone at the operating
system level yeah it's completely
de-googled
you know it has its own app store and
all that so you're not relying on the
google play store or anything
and uh and we you know like you know
trying to side load apps or all that for
i mean the thing about this phone is a
lot of just
normal people that aren't aren't like
yeah trying to jailbreak their phones
root their phones
and all that got that and then yeah i
mean that's that's
it's just a huge problem that we're
reliant on in my opinion anti-free
speech hardware i mean it's ironic to me
that apple's motto used to be think
different and now they ban apps who
think different
um yep and uh uh so i mean it's
or google which was do no evil and then
now there's company policy they got rid
of that motto
and all that and that's and that's why i
think you know like you know we're a
startup
but ultimately and uh and i i don't have
like a pr team of like a thousand people
like these people
like i'm just you know coming on this
podcast you know
um uh you know just trying to share the
word um
but i mean it's it's it's it's just if
we don't have our own hardware in my
opinion we're screwed
it's the weirdest thing that people were
like it's a thing saying it's a honeypot
like yeah the phone is a trap i'm like
what do you think your phone already
does
it's a honeypot welcome to modern
technologies well they went phones
they're a hundred miles
they wouldn't attack me this much if it
was and then two yeah i mean they've
doxxed
unless they're trying to convince
everyone you're on the level by
attacking you saying
see look they're attacking him that must
prove it the double double cross the
double double yes the false flag false
flag false flag
well because of these articles and
because of will summer's article
my mom got doxxed and all that and
they're releasing that is a coordinated
harassment campaign from will summer
in my opinion and uh uh and
i mean and it's just i mean luckily my
mom's scottish so she's tough
um she was tough growing up in the best
way possible
um and uh and they've done because my
mom she worked on the
i mean she's an incredibly smart woman
and and a great mother uh she uh
she worked on the um the star wars
project under reagan
um and all that and then yeah so they're
trying to say like on this honeypot and
all that just because my mom
you know worked worked on a project
under the reagan administration
and all that and uh i mean it's it's
crazy honestly that that my mom has gone
to i mean coming to the political world
i almost like
i i mean i knew what was coming in the
sense of
of you know but i was so well-liked by
the left-wing media you know i was doing
interviews with them and all that and i
was fine i wanted to give it up because
uh for free speech and all that i mean
it sounds cheesy but it's actually true
um and uh but to me to see like yeah my
mom get doxed you know these people
write fake articles
um and uh for people that hadn't even
touched the phone yet
i mean it's it's amazing when i think
about how we got to this point you know
i was talking about i'm still
shell-shocked honestly you know i was
talking about algorithmic uh psychosis
and i want i'm thinking about it from
like the perspective of the psychopaths
and who live in the in the mirror world
in the in the in the in the upside down
or whatever
and you know how did how did we come to
this position of
knowing computers of no like how look we
knew about bitcoin
in the early days most people didn't
even find out about bitcoin until like
2016 or something
and i'm like i was on the internet as
long as i can remember my family had
compuserve on dos
you know and then so then we got windows
3.1 we had aol
i've always had access to the internet
to learn and read whatever i wanted
and i guess that makes uh it makes you a
deviant because you have access to the
summation of human knowledge or so so
much knowledge at the time
regular people other millennials didn't
get the internet until they were
teenagers
so they didn't necessarily grow up with
it as heavily like i was programming
stuff i was doing video games
i was doing flash animations and flash
websites when i was like 12 or 13. it's
amazing
yeah i built my first computer when i
was like 7. so here i am with all the
access to this information totally
independent
these other people don't and i think
that that might be where this like hard
bifurcation
starts the people who are internet savvy
who understand the rules of the internet
don't argue with trolls it means they
win
but then you get these other kids who
aren't internet savvy and they're just
watching nothing but this horror content
and so they become insane and we become
discerning
and then you get tough to say because me
and eric are both we're like almost
different generations i'm 42 you're 22.
yeah wow 20 years apart that's crazy
we're both internet dudes like i didn't
get in
until i was 16 aol but i'm sorry is
1996 or four or five or something 1994 i
think whatever you're born
79 79 yeah so right right around there
you look like a product of the 70s yeah
i feel like
just barely but it's the critical
thinking skills and i don't know if it
matters when you were born if you're
going to have critical thinking skills
realizing what you see isn't necessarily
like if you see something a thousand
times that doesn't mean that it happened
a thousand times
i don't know what do you i don't know i
don't know i don't know
i just think that there's two um
different universes that exist
yeah it seems like there are people who
live in the paranoia you know it's
really funny
uh there's this very very high profile
podcaster who apparently um
said that i was one of these people who
lit who's to to online
and uh you know like oh there's these
people they're just two
online and they live in this world and
i'm like
the people on the left who believe in
all of this algorithmic psychosis
and are completely unaware of it they're
the people who are too online
the people who believe that donald trump
was a russian agent
that's because of the two online people
i'm afraid that it's their lack of
critical thinking skills and if they
just watched a lot of like violent
action movies they'd they'd think that
that was normal too they're they've
they've been
how do you how do you tell someone who's
spent
15 years of their 25-year life
that everything they've seen and
experienced on social media as they were
growing up and learned
was wrong you encouraged them to take
suicide here's here's an example the
only way
imagine you're in an aircraft hangar
massive we're talking like 50
80 000 square feet this massive
aircraft hangar and we're all looking
around at stuff
constantly walking over and asking
what's that ooh that's interesting and
these people are in the corner
staring at this the corner of the room
pointing
thinking that's reality it's almost like
the allegory of the
of the shadows in the cave yeah yeah
yeah that they've been sitting in this
cave
seeing nothing but police brutality
shadow puppets
and so when you're at the door of the
cave yelling that's
not real life they're like you're crazy
these people are conspiracy theorists
it's a rabbit hole
you know it's like what i can't remember
the exact quote from breitbart about
walking towards the fire
but uh you know
people think i can't remember the exact
quote but someone said to me something
similar so it might be breitbart that
people are scared to walk towards the
fire because i think they'll get burned
but the other side is freedom
and you know you walk past it and then
everything's normal and you're fine
these people are trapped in the cave
yeah because the shadows on the wall it
is real life
it's just one tiny fragment of real life
right exactly
so they're living in this paranoid
delusional state they look look
what they say when they're like when
they say when they say things like
police are hunting black people
jeez we know that's not real but imagine
you're 18.
and you were eight years old and you had
no no life experience you were playing
hopscotch
a few years later you get on facebook
for the first time and what do you see
remember that book
we had with um azra yeah
the crt book it was the book where the
little kid was like seeing a video on
the internet
like eight-year-old kid and then and
then saying like mommy what's this the
mom's like no don't watch this
and then the little girl finally snaps
one day like i know the truth about what
the police are doing
it's because people realize you'll make
money
off of police brutality videos well i
think i figured out how to get through
to these people or maybe something that
can help is
my mom i used to play video games a lot
my mom would be like it's not real this
isn't real this isn't
but what she didn't realize is if she
just told me this is real
but there's more look these are also
things that are real
so acknowledge that what i was doing is
real like if i'm playing a video game
and it's a character and a story in my
mind
that is reality it's just a fragment of
this greater reality so if you
acknowledge like critical race
all these theories and things yeah they
are real they're they are valid concepts
but there's
more there's a there's a meme where it's
like there's this guy playing video
games
and then his dad walks in and he goes
hey do you want to play this cool new
game
basically you have to go on adventures
you try and raise money to buy certain
to buy artifacts and items to improve
your character's stats become better
equipped
stronger and faster make friends and
then he's like yeah you make friends
along the way and the dude's like wow
sounds awesome
and then he shoves them out the door and
he's like have fun it's life dude
life imitates art and all that stuff you
know thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you